what was wrong with Communism stalinism
implementation of Communism in the
Soviet Union why did it go wrong
so and in what ways did it not go wrong
in what ways did it succeed let me start
with the second part of that question
and that's a very difficult one to
answer in part because
I morally and ethically am opposed to
any form of authoritarianism or
dictatorship and often when you talk
about the successes of a government or
what it did developmentally that might
have been positive we have to abstract
ourselves from what we morally believe
and just just kind of look at the record
right
I would say that the Soviet experiment
started off by in Lenin's time as the
attempt to kind of just hold a holding
action
hey we don't really have the conditions
to rule this country we have the support
of the working class or most of it but
the working class is only you know three
percent of the the population you know
the peasantry is really against us a lot
of this three percent of the population
has died in war and half of them
supported the mensheviks and the more
moderate socialists anyway but
the alternative in their minds was going
to be a far-right reaction you know some
sort of General taking power in a coup
or whatever else or just them ending up
back in prison because a lot of them
were in prison on the Czar or just
killed so they figured
all right we're gonna have a holding
action where we maintain as much of this
territory of the old Russian Empire as
possible we'll try to slowly Implement
changes restabilize the economy through
something called a new economic program
which was kind of a form of
social democracy if you if you will
because it allowed market exchange for
the peasants
um combined with State ownership of
Industries in the cities and
for a while it seemed to be working the
revolution never came that they were
expecting in Western Europe but in
Russia itself they were able to
restabilize things by the middle or end
of the the 1920s and they were able to
build more of a popular base for some of
their policies because people who had
seen the chaos of World War One and
Revolution and then Civil War kind of
just wanted stability and after a decade
plus a war if you had a government that
was able to give you enough to eat in a
job you know that was good enough for
them
then Stalin came into power and he
wanted to rapidly industrialize in his
logic was the revolution's not going to
come in the west we need to build
socialism in one country and we need to
catch up with the West we need to turn
ourselves into industrial Powerhouse as
quickly as possible
and that's where you got forced
collectivization to try to increase the
productivity of Russian agriculture
through State ownership of previously
fragmented agricultural Holdings and
through the
implementation of mechanization so bring
in more machines to make agriculture
more productive all under State
ownership
plus more ambitious attempts to build
heavy industry through five-year plans
now
I say this kind of coolly but we know in
practice what that meant you know forced
collectivization was a disaster I mean
first of all I think it was built on the
faulty premise that scale always equals
more productivity when in fact
especially in agriculture but in any
field it's a little bit more complicated
than that and it led to millions of
deaths you know it led to famine it led
to a host of other problems
um industrialization in the way that it
happened under Stalin also kind of
unbalanced the Soviet economy to lean
too heavy towards heavy industry not
enough or medium or light industry but
[Music]
this did mean especially the um The
Five-Year Plan in industrialization did
manage to put Russia on a different
developmental trajectory
so
by the time the post-war period came
the one it might have gave them the
ability to survive the Nazi invasion to
begin with it was a complicated question
and then by the time the post-war period
came uh Russia had kind of jumped ahead
of its developmental trajectory in a way
that a lot of other countries didn't do
there are a few examples like Japan is
one to manage to if you kind of ran a
scenario where Japan would be in the
1870s 1880s and ran it 100 times the
Japan of the post-war period is kind of
one of the best outcomes right and I
think that that you could say that about
Russian Economic Development its ability
to catch up at a certain level to the
West
and then after that of course um
later on
um as economies got more complex as they
kind of moved Beyond uh regular heavy
industry and as as the main stable of
the economy the Russian economy in its
command system was unable to adapt and
cope and ended up falling back behind uh
the West Again by the by the 1970s so
all this is a very long story to say
that a lot went wrong and Russia the
economic picture is actually a little
bit more complicated politically
um I I think it's just a small party
without much pop of the support but with
real popular sport in a couple cities
when a lot without a lot of popular
support Empire wide
um took power and they felt they
couldn't give back power
and they kept holding on to power and
eventually among their ranks in these
conditions uh one of History's great
tyrants took power and was able to
justify what he was doing
um in the context of the Russian nation
and development but also all the threats
that came from abroad through you know
the Civil War wasn't just a civil war it
was really an invasion by by many um
Imperial Powers all around the world
um as well so I think a lot of it was
conditions and Circumstance
um and I guess the the question really
is to what role ideology played was
there something within the Socialist
tradition that might have lend itself to
authoritarianism